This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Sam.
And I'm Neil. Recently, I met up with an old school friend. I hadn't seen for years. We talked
for hours. All right, sounds like you had a good chinwag, a long and pleasant conversation between
friends, which is great because in this programme, we're talking about talking. We'll be discussing
conversations, the exchange of ideas, thoughts and feelings that happens when people talk to each
other. And as usual, we'll be learning some new vocabulary as well. With the rise of Twitter
and social media, which encourages us to give our opinion on a subject without always listening
in return, some think the ass of conversation is being lost. But luckily, there are still millions
of us who love to talk. Chat, chinwag and chatter away. In fact, in 2012, a competition in Latvia
broke the world record for the longest telephone conversation. So, Neil, my question is this.
How long did this record-breaking conversation last? Was it? A, 24 hours and four minutes.
B, 54 hours and four minutes. Or C, 84 hours and four minutes.
I'll guess A, 24 hours and four minutes, after which they probably fell asleep.
Okay, Neil, I'll reveal the correct answer later in the programme.
During a long career, DJ and BBC Radio presenter, Nehal Atherneiker, has had conversations with
hundreds of people. Now, he's used these experiences to write a book entitled Let's Talk.
How to have better conversations. Here, Nehal tells another radio presenter, Michael Rosen,
of BBC Radio 4's Word of Mouth, about the influence of his mother, who also love talking to people
in her job as a nurse. Well, it gave me the sense that you are enriched by listening. And this was
of course pre-social media, which is of course encouraged us to project to transmit more than receive.
So it meant that I guess I was conscious of the experiences of others and wanted to try and
understand them. Also partially, Michael, it was a survival instinct because I was a little brown
boy in a predominantly white school, a state school in the 1980s. For Nehal, good conversation
involves listening as much as speaking. By listening, we find out things about the person we're
talking to, which in turn help us understand ourselves. This is why Nehal says we are enriched
by listening. We're improved by having something else added. As a British Asian boy growing up
in a white community, Nehal also thinks conversation was a way for him to make friends and find
protection. He says having conversations was a survival instinct. The human instinct to do
something in a dangerous situation that will keep them safe from harm.
Nehal sees an important difference between listening simply to reply and listening to understand.
When we listen to reply, we're thinking about the next thing we want to say, more than trying
to understand the other person's point of view. Listening to understand, on the other hand,
helps build bridges. Improve relationships between people who are very different or do not like
each other. Here's Nehal again in conversation with BBC Radio Falls, word of mouth.
So, conversation can build bridges and it is proven through history that conversation has
and that conversation can be seen as an art form. And that's one of the things I want us to
understand. It's not just tittle tattle. It's not just shouting at each other on social media.
It's not two politicians talking over each other. Good conversation brings people together.
Unlike tittle tattle. Talk about other people's lives that is usually unkind,
disapproving or untrue. And good conversation involves taking turns, not talking over someone,
trying to silence people by talking more loudly, forcefully and persistently than them.
Hopefully, Nehal's tips can help us all have better conversations, encounter new ideas and make
friends. So Sam, did you do any of these things when you met up with your old school friend?
I think so. We both listened to each other. There was no tittle tattle, but a little bit of gossip.
Before we knew it, a couple of hours had passed. But not as much time as those record-breaking
telephone conversations I mentioned earlier. Ah yes, in your question, you asked how long the world's
longest telephone conversation lasted. I guessed it was an incredible 24 hours and four minutes.
Was I right? Well, Nehal, I'm afraid that was the wrong answer. In fact, the record-breaking
conversation lasted 54 hours and four minutes. About the same as 540 programmes of six minutes English.
Wow. Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned from this programme on the art of good
conversations, starting with Chinwag, a long and pleasant conversation between friends.
When something is enriched, it's improved by having something else added to it.
The survival instinct is the basic instinct in humans and animals to do something in a dangerous
situation that will keep them alive. If you build bridges, you improve relationships between people
who are very different or do not like each other. Tittle tattle is talk about other people's lives
that is usually unkind, disapproving or untrue. And finally, if you talk over someone, you silence
or drown them out by talking more loudly than them. That's the end of our conversation,
but remember to join us soon for more trending topics and useful vocabulary. Bye for now.